now they're calling it black Tuesday in
France today seems like this is striking
rail workers starting a campaign of
strikes that they say will last for
months it's all supposed to be a thing
of the past brave new world of economic
reforms we're going to bring the unions
to heel and usher in the sort of labor
laws we used to on this side of the
channel so is this a doomed last stand
on the old guard or a genuine threat
that could leave the reformist agenda in
the sidings alive from Paris's Pascal
kang-hee he's chairman of business
France and with me here in the studios I
got des male she's France analyst at the
economic Economist Intelligence Unit I
got I'll start with you
how important is this for mr. Mackall on
this battle well I would say it's very
important for mr. McComb because this
battle is part of wider plans to reform
the French labor markets to improve
increase the flexibility of the labor
markets change the welfare system
towards a flexicurity Nordic style model
and also attract foreign investment so
this year the government is going to
focus on three main areas as I said
reforming the welfare system through a
reform of unemployment benefits and also
apprenticeships schemes the government
is also going to change lows in the
migration system to attract highly
skilled migrants and we hope that this
is going to attract foreign investors to
France in the long run at least
hello Pascal let me bring you in at this
point what's it being like in France
today the thirty-day I mean despite the
strike and the fact that this morning we
announced amazing results we have the
best reserve of our ability to attract
foreign investor in France 1,300
projects are being essentially
established creating or maintaining 33
jobs so in any respect is a very limit
days so ideas like like the key being
for transformation which hopefully will
bear some even beneficial and going
forth but what's the mood like among the
public I mean we were hearing today
something like four and a half million
French rail users were disrupted today
it's the traveling public on the side of
the Union here on the side of Monsieur
Makarov
no it will be 32 early to step the tuple
matters many people are using the best
technology to work on home
they have been literally coming back
here in Paris after a long history can
yesterday that can tell you that this
morning at 9:00 a.m. we were having a
food back audience when we are
announcing the results about this
investment coming in France which
actually is the real good news of the
day
no there is no questions that this
strike and this process is going to be a
difficult one but as mr. amer decided
this morning that the intention is to
keep a perfect service with the essence
s we consider this a fantastic company
but they need to be continued to be
transformed so that we really get the
benefit and continue to use it as a way
to attract new investment even
intrapreneur in france entrepreneur from
abroad i got a lot of people i think in
the UK will be surprised at union
membership in france it's actually much
lower than expected but the union's
really do punch their weight don't they
in France yes that's right actually a
union membership is quite low in France
that as you mentioned unions are very
powerful however we think that mr. McCoy
is going to be able to push through the
reforms first because as we just said
public is supporting the reforms and is
not supporting the strikes around 70% of
French people actually support his
reforms second
mr. myko is a strong problem and
majority and finally he can go with the
crease if he wants to
is it any coincidence that this is blown
up on the railway so I mean French
railway workers are uniquely protected
almost they have jobs for life they have
extremely generous pensions very early
retirement is it any coincidence that
this is one of the battlegrounds
well it's no coincidence the railway
system has always been a battleground
between the government and unions and I
would say that most French people would
remember the 1995 strikes and as you
mentioned the railway workers are very
much protected they enjoy pension
benefits they can retire at age 52 if
there are train drivers and they have
job for life contracts and that's the
main point here the government wants to
scrap these contracts
and make it so that employees of the
SNCF would have regular private sector
contracts and this is quite a
contentious point for his people the
early retirement at 52 for train drivers
dates back to the days of steam where
they all got coal in their lungs doesn't
it well it was even earlier than 52 at
the time it's been raised recently it
was 50 only a few years ago and it's
gradually rising towards 52 at the
moment already very contentious well
Pascal you mentioned overseas investment
into France do you worry that this kind
of strike is going to deter foreign
investors obviously this could be only
portrayed as being very worth the lean
times what the different discussions we
have with Leicester tell us is that they
very much appreciate and have been
waiting that for a long time that France
go through a transformation we
Illustrated over the last six to eight
months that in a matter of few months
the ability managed to have a much more
flexible workplace which is critical
when your investor we also adjust all of
the tax rate into the average of
Europe's and we continue to offer
something very very precious to investor
which is a unique talent pool very
competitive as you know the cost of
researcher in France is one of the
lowest of Europe partially in fact
intense incentives it also because we
produce every year like a clock in
excess of 40,000 engineers all the quest
of the ground in these coming years are
going to be the quest of hands and the
reasons why we want to produce more
engineers we want to go back to the
industry and we want to be very
welcoming to the talent all of that
together should actually overpass any
doubt that people may have a beautiful
stripe like the one we have right now
all right you gonna leave it there I'm
afraid
Pascal canny I got de magie thanks very
much for joining